[Música]
oi
button
[Música]
e aí a hora de assistir o canal tudo bem
com você antes deixar lá avisa pra você
quer de paris fechou o final de semana
ingresso r$15 para baratos e não ocorreu
agora você não vai pegar lá as controlar
tudo ocupado as lá no fundo ainda tem
vaga na equipe de milão bem mas hoje a
gente vai falar sobre esses amigo que se
acha a gente mude mas já chega pegando
as coisas que eu tenho um negócio pra
falar pra vocês sabem que já é meu amigo
demais fica pegando meu canal ele
invadiu a sala e ir lá no quase
[Música]
e aí galera que assistir o canal tudo
bem com vocês agora eu mesmo em original
não é original ou seja lá essas coisas
mas estamos aqui para mais um vídeo que
você agora o meu amigo na carreira então
evento na hora exatamente em 20 canal e
possa a cada mês é um jogo que era lucas
fazem muito tempo não se vê toulouse
está 'bombando' ajeitar tudo a última
vez que a gente vê o botafoto e botar
fora daquela imagem que tem um encontro
em brasília nós estilo aí inscritos foi
muito massa lá pra gente tem amizade faz
muito tempo embora não se veja com
freqüência também porque ele morava em
brasília morar no piauí quando ficam a
faltar de fumar em são paulo então ficou
difícil a gente se ver mais gente a mim
eu resolvi falar hoje sobre o tipo e
amigo pra vocês e vai submeter os bons e
os ruins é um bom e terminem como tu
falou lá no começo é um tipo de amigo
que se acham que anda pegando as coisas
da gente que vai vetar com as luzes da
dieta contendo a gente está com as cores
da gente e temos a micção íntimo que
essa intimidamos amigo chegado a gente
faz tudo dá o sangue e fica pedindo água
em pegá lá pra mim lá pegar nem que tem
vergonha bem gelada e levantou a tampa
da privada não residente tem vergonha
beijada digo nem amigo de verdade que
quando é colega retrato diferente ela
também colega gente buscar água
mas se for amigo de verdade e apresentar
cópia da chave é exatamente isso não
falam bater para não acordar de volta e
pronto e já no mercado aumentou no fim
eu achava lá em casa quando o cara
colega se ele pedir água você busca mas
é mais e busca a do filtro sempre foi
amigo de verdade os e xinga ele porque
está pedindo nada é porque a atenção
minha o nome de verdade para ele dar um
pouquinho de água do total esperado que
é chato pra casa lá buscar água em que
tem vergonha vá buscar a regra desgraças
e vai da poesia com cara faz ela abrir a
geladeira mas desse exame equipe nem sei
que não goste nand está nunca guarde
abre a geladeira dos outros guabi a paz
ou tem algo que ela não tem mais nada lá
dentro não antigamente era mais fácil
fazer o exame
antigamente a amizade era sincera
sincera mas verdadeira criança a pessoa
quando ela tá começando a conhecer as
pessoas se prestar atenção
ela é mais parceiro cai quando quando se
rala já vem preocupando marmota terra o
cara vai bota até hoje se cair no meu
caro quando cresce pode baixar a tensão
quando cresce um exemplo aqui o tétano
câmera no cairo está empinando de motos
cresceu 18 anos de bush clinton acha que
a vida é tudo o cara anda de bicicleta o
cara em pneu da bicicleta na volta o
pneu da frente da bicicleta eu torço
pela bicicleta
nesse momento eu to completar o trajeto
onde eu quero que caia quando caiu entre
para e grita uma gordinha então
antigamente a amizade era a maior
gostosa diferente hoje em dia é mais
difícil fazer a mímica em amizade faz
você sofrer também pode sofrer porque se
você cair
amigo de uma limpeza no machucado fez no
machucado kospi baixou de deus ou era do
disco cair nunca foi dado em exprimir
cacique ml no cassino
já ofereci a vermelha negócio a ver com
raiva que passarã e toca macho é é tanto
bt não tem aquele amigo também que acha
que adicionar a orelha não é esse é
difícil qualquer coisa que se fala ele
discorda e nem sabe que ele não falou
mais nada minha irmã que ele tá se é ele
diz que viu em algum lugar e ele gosta
de dizer isso aí não mas sei que é assim
ao céu é preto não é rosa porque eu vi
eu vi ontem o moleque está com febre
o cara pouco face à glicose e costa rica
costa não há um clima também pode
participar
totti chama futebol tem um destaque de
pai e mãe marca
button fez dele e ele acabou achando que
o time também é um amigo que eu tenho
raiva que é um amigo que eu chamo de
amigo exemplo é o seguinte essa amiga é
o seguinte ele você conhece ele você
conhece e marquinhos seja mais do que
ele você com ele mais do que já passou
por poucas e boas com esse inimigo seja
livre de várias coisas na vida e na o
cão no meio da rua é só é inclinado pneu
de moto é que correm é bem é fazendo
tudo isso pediu bomba haiti chega na sua
casa pra vocês eu me beleza ele sempre
não só parece um anjo ea sua mãe usa ele
de exemplo olha aí o luca talvez nunca
se tendo locais ela das coisas meu filho
e começa a falar mal de mim públicas e
sinimbu vale na wae seis amigas do
estudo final de semana provocou cinco
meses
a gente sabe por que você está no
terceiro ano o lucro está na quinta
série estava falsificando os documentos
para falar passou de ano e é exatamente
aí a mãe dele acreditar que eu e uso no
dia a sério está vendo tendo louca viu
tendo lucro no ano passado esquentado
mesmo jeito moleque e siminina zeloso
índio nunca sabe seladas com the filth
com raiva porque eu quero faltar nunca
mas não posso que o diabo lucas é meu
amigo mas eu posso falar a verdade só
tem um lado bom nessa história que
quando eu que sou o cão também são os
atuais amigo luca não é só faz as coisas
a desgraça tudo pelo mundo e faz um
túnel na casa do lucas eu sou hoje é o
anjo a lavar o lucro fazendo o êxito na
paz
esse menino é zeloso tem que saber
comprar eu vi o trt s n no ano passado
por um amigo que você vai se identificar
mais aqui nesse vídeo é o homem pidão
todo mundo tem essa todo mundo tem uma
equipe dão em qualquer idade em qualquer
idade e mpe não é só vai aparecer quando
você tiver uma coisa que ninguém tem e o
pior é que esse amigo pidão além de lhe
pedir avisa todo mundo que você tem
vai fazer falta aí é só sobrou 2 a 1
merecedor de sozinho
é isso aí não tem nada não dá para na
minha opinião o que o amigo me dão é
aquele que ainda que a exigência porque
tem também entendem que pede é já é ruim
é aquele gatinho sua casa aí o que comer
banana que a banda pilera não pode ser
panambi marsans sabia que tinha banda
feira prenderam ainda um tique taque
sinan sequer se pode dormir lá ele já
que só quer se for do dolosa megadeth da
rosa ou então do órgão é o nome eu sou
feliz comenta meu gosto é eu tenho um
favorito eu e shaq tormento sinto o
poder da mente azul seria de maracujá e
te puxa de para esse remédio mas tem
gosto de conversar em sete sabores
autênticos itaqui menta tem o incrível
dupla sabor morango em também ontem lamy
tem favor laranja e cereja o maracujá é
de fruta é esse tipo de função da globo
já está com menos massa urbana tem o meu
ver do que é o tormento e sinto
profundamente a juke é muito bom porque
é forte e é bom pois boca pois não é que
eu tenho esse problema tanto que chama
de a cidade como quando viajo fazer show
acho que quando for falar com o pessoal
da tictac falaram que eu tenho agora
pode mandar a quem muito azul se pode
perceber no fim da minha boca pude e tem
mais como esconder
o negócio é o seguinte ó vocês viram que
o cristiano ronaldo invadiu no início e
ele vai invadir outro canal já fica
igual quem é e já fica aí ó ano a vazão
de itaqui tamo junto é nóis como embaixo
que você acha que o time pode então isso
é muito obrigado vocês vão gostar desse
vídeo já sabe aplicar aqui embaixo em
gostei aqui no youtube é aquele que
zinho volta lá no facebook porque se
você vai clicar em curtir lá que é muito
bom olha só de beleza vai comentar aqui
embaixo é o tipo de amigo que você mais
tem rádio com o tipo de amigo que você
mais gosta de marcar seu amigo boca pois
já no facebook também viu aqui lucas
leiva na hora participou comigo você
quiser se inscrever no canal dele é só
clicar aqui agora
o bumbá é votar em você que tá pelo
celular um link do do canal de tal
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo tapa
pelo celular clica lá vai se inscrever
directo no canal do brasileiro é nós
galera